bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france on le voit que
chaque année pour le président russe est
un rendez vous très important pour
quelles raisons selon vous bah écoutez
c'est important à la fois parce que ça
lui permet de rester évidemment en
contact avec la nation et et cette année
en particulier parce que ça a été
évidemment une année très difficile à
cause de la pandémie
et puis ça a été l'année de toutes les
réformes de la constitution donc
monsieur poutine ne pouvait pas ne pas
manquer cette occasion auquel il tient
beaucoup 1 depuis très longtemps et donc
cette année un corps particulier
d'autant plus que contre nous il ya
malheureusement il ya des petits bruits
sur sa santé sur son état donc tu es
rumeurs bon surtout dans une certaine
presse occidentale ou qu'elle évidemment
une prête pas attention parce que ça
fait un petit peu aisée trop de la rue
la plus basse donc voilà je crois que
c'est c'est s'était partiellement
important pour rassurer et comme je
l'entends du en rue jusqu'à présent ça
commence évidemment toutes les questions
qui ont été posées tourner autour du
coded évidemment de la vaccination est
ce que d y aura suffisamment de vaccins
de la pauvreté qu'il ya des chiffres qui
l'a rassuré de l'aide gouvernementale
house et aux secteurs qui sont les plus
impactées en quelque sorte tout ce qu'il
transport aérien l'agriculture la
construction
il ya eu d'autres questions de politique
étrangère on y reviendra peut-être
évidemment donc voila un petit peu et
j'ai trouvé un président calme
habillée dans un costume bleu cravate
bleue alors que son conseiller de
précieux et cravate rouge donc tout ça
est fait le bien organisés comme
toujours bien huilée chaque chaque
région on voit défiler dans des andes
dans des locaux beaucoup de journalistes
qui posent des questions et s'est
transmis comme ça d'une dune d'un an de
tout les coins de la russie le présent
poutine prend des notes
écoute attentivement des questions qui
sont parfois un petit peu aiguë donc je
crois que c'est un exercice qui est
qu'il n'est pas usé et quoi malgré les
longues d'aného kalliste on suit qui
intéressent l'opinion publique les
journalistes et qui me semble être
écoutés à la fois en russie et à
l'extérieur voilà on peut le
l'impression la première impression
qu'on peut tirer de déjà de ces trois
heures oui c'est ça alors vous le disait
il ya bien sûr une ni deux il y avait
une invention il ya beaucoup plus de
trois heures il ya beaucoup de
d'information vous le disais qu'il
remonte du terrain vous pensez que ça
lui sert à vladimir poutine dans sa
gouvernance
comment ça il ya beaucoup d'informations
qui remonte du terrain vous le disiez
vous même et est ce que ça lui sert à
vladimir poutine dans sa gouvernance
oui oui ça lui sert bon d'abord tout
tout homme politique surtout montre
qu'il s'intéresse aux jo et je crois
qu'ils écoutent
il écoute il prend des notes et ensuite
ça lui permet de relancer les
gouverneurs qui doivent évidemment
écouté les doléances peau parfois
certains journalistes prennent la
liberté critique est leur gouverneur de
montrer qu'il ya certains manquements et
donc c'est une manière je veux dire de
démocratie directe qui permet ensuite au
président poutine vladimir poutine de
relancer soit blâmé soin de rappeler à
l'ordre
mais surtout de faire avancer les choses
alors évidemment il peut pas il peut pas
intervenir sur 15700 un problème à la
fois mais il en prend les plus
importantes qui se recoupent par exemple
il ya une personne ont pas parlé que de
haute politique de santé vous savez
certainement que les problèmes les
ordures était délicat il s'est créé des
gens des 12-19 puisqu'il n'y avait pas
de d'endroit pour incinération truquer
les verdures des ordures et 2 des
camions partent est de moscou et les
déposaient donc une personne n'a posé
par la cdu questions importantes faut
pas l'oublier est ce que c'est une
question qui a été a été repoussé les
dits non pas du tout on y veille
évidemment maintenant on a moins de
ressources mais où keller aucun grand
objectif national qui devait commencer à
mettre en oeuvre à partir de pas de
cette année de janvier quoi ils ont pris
six mois de retard mais aucun n'a été
commise et doug et les projets nationaux
certains par exemple correspondre à une
une réponse à la à la pandémie par
exemple il a parlé de 39 milles ou
quarante mille écoles et bien en 21 il a
dit il faut absolument les branchés sur
l'informatique l'internet parce que la
somme de cours pour devront est
poursuivi
voilà donc l'équipement de tout le
secteur universitaire et scolaire doigté
trash et qui est loin d'être le cas
maintenant et beaucoup d'écoles ont dû
certainement fermés travailler en régime
réduit évidemment souffrir de la
situation le président russe qui a aussi
fait un point sur la situation
économique de son pays selon lui la
russie s'en sort mieux que certains pays
c'est vrai selon vous balala j'ai pas vu
le bon là j'ai pas entendu ça il a
plutôt parlé de l'aide de l'inflation
bon le d'après bon aussi et la russie
s'en sort oui s'en sort mais tout mieux
que la france a la une baisse de pipe de
7 à 8% alors que nous on va on va être
autour de 9 pour l'allemagne t5 et demie
enfin on va pas rentrer dans des
situations de tableau d'honneur ou pas
alors trois chiffres que j'ai retenu
qu'il paraisse qu'on a un porto et qui
meurent ou presque étonné quand lui est
arrivé au pouvoir le taux de pauvreté
est à 29 % de la population en 2017 12,3
est aujourd'hui très et demi alors que
beaucoup de gens pensaient que c'était
sa dépasser 15 donc voilà le chief qu'il
a donné il faut regarder et il dit que
le mon objectif c'est de les réduire de
moitié à six et demi donc voilà un
chiffre important
le deuxième c'est l'inflation elle est
autour de 4 4,1 donc là aussi elle n'a
pas augmenté parce que le vent en
problèmes de rareté
on pourrait croire que les prix
augmentent surtout quand les frais de
distribution sont gonflés et le
troisième c'est intéressant c'est le
paquet dead qu'on appelle qui il a
évalué à 4,5 pour cent du pib' alors
c'est moins que certains pays comme le
japon 10 % chez nous mais attention sans
rentrer dans un débat de spécialistes
quand par le hacker dead il y avait
crédit il ya les garanties quoi c'est
pas de l'argent frais qui arrive pour
soutenir des entreprises qui ont dû
fermer leurs portes
donc il a il a montré les différentes a
donc quatre et demi c'est global il est
difficile de comparer
ce que chaque pays a son propre
programme et et le manque nature sont
pas toujours les mêmes quoi alors nous
ne savons pas si vladimir poutine a été
mise au courant de cette information on
l'a appris ce matin emmanuel macron a
été testé positif aux qu'ovide 19 votre
réaction par rapport à cela et surtout
est-ce que ça peut avoir un impact sur
la gestion de la crise sanitaire en
france mais au niveau repeint aussi
parce qu'on a appris aussi que charles
michel allait être mise en quarantaine
le président du conseil européen la
rencontre emmanuel macron lundi et puis
aussi le premier ministre portugais
aussi qui est à l' isolement
bah écoutez ma première réaction c'est
où on est désolé parce que le président
bak rond comme vous c'est si je reprends
leur russe voulait malgré toutes
les critiques malgré d'affaires n'a
failli malgré tout mais il le père liste
est à établir un dialogue avec la russie
est un affront dialogue ouvert donc ce
dialogue certainement leur prendre du
retard
et en ce qui concerne l'europe
effectivement au moment où byden arrive
vous monsieur tron va partir l'europe
fait mauvaise figure quoi à la fois
économiquement des habits d'une chine
qualifiée triomphante sans aucune ironie
la chine sans les sorties c'est un débat
actuel et économique non une manière
sanitaires d'ailleurs c'est intéressant
parce que si on encore une seconde je
m'échappe pas quelqu'un dit adam né à
pourrir poutine quels sont les
interlocuteurs vous avez aimé dur et où
il a répondu il ya prés diplomatique
moi je dialogue avec tout le monde je
place pas les bons et les méchants
tout le monde cherche à son intérêt mais
vous n'avez pas nommer la chine et voyez
moi j'ai des relations d'amitié l'équipe
jean ping
c'est rare voilà donc c'est intéressant
qu il a un corps tenu à montrer alors
bon on verra ce qui se passera le test
unis mais en ce qui concerne l'europe
l'ours puisque on aura une
redistribution sur le chaîne mondiale
internationale on a eu chine puissante
qui monte
on a une amérique est ce que va revenir
ou pas prudente c'est beaucoup de choses
une réussite qui finalement sont sans
arrêt tellement bien
qui est fable ordonné qu'ils essayent de
régler ses problèmes avec silence pays
alors que l'europe
le quatrième pilier de l'or noir mondial
je ne dirais pas qui s'écroule mais il
est un peu faiblard cas est normalement
dans un monde multipolaire qui dès lors
qu'elle veut de la russie si l'europe
est absente
ça manque ça manquait tour quand même
citoyens européens qui voulons une
grande sécurité dans le cadre
paneuropéen je peux pas encore dire d'un
petit canal
si nous ne sommes sur les moins présents
- qui fait est un peu handicapé par ses
soins de santé qu'on n'a pas pu régler
les problèmes économiques et sont liés
c'est vraiment dommage
dans l'eure a perdu des mois précieux
j'espère conclure on va se rendre du
côté de l'elysée dans un instant pour
faire le point sur l'information qu'on
évoquait emmanuel macron positif aux
copies du jeu mais sur les relations
russo américaines et il y a fait
allusion vladimir poutine il a semblé
tendre une perche à radio maidan non non
bon vous savez sur toi et je lui
j'écoute toutes les questions et est pas
non il a simplement dit bon chez qui la
ilaha illa on dira il a félicité ses
tardivement il veut trois jours quoi il
a attendu que finalement que la lettre
officielle pour sembler un peu juridique
quoi on peut importe voit pas clown et
là dessus non simplement il a dit
j'espère que monsieur byden qu'on va
établir des relations ouvertes
coopérative voilà passé j'ai à dire
c'est normalien s'éduque comme un tocard
yens nouveaux cas autant il était
chaleureux avec son ami jean ping avec
ba ln il reste prudent parce que il on
va pas vendre la peau de l'ours
surtout le avant de l'avoir tué sans
aucune ironie
donc il faut voir finalement on attend
alors tout le monde sait qu en dehors de
ça le gros problème c'est les soldes 2cv
q vous et pour les problèmes le reset
les colts de 10 ce qui a été établi
entre obama et medvedev en 2009 où les
relais les missiles devrait être qu'un
sens les porter à l'ailé les lanceurs et
bien ils vont expirer en deux ans en
février prochain c'est à dire demain
et si il s'est accord n'est pas
reconduit tous les accords et je suis ça
depuis des décennies tous les accords et
les fêtes vont disparaître donc tout
larmes ce contrôle tous les sites web
tout le dialogue entre russie et états
unis il paraître c'est énorme
merci beaucoup à vous un gène berg
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions d'avoir commenté avec mon
cette conférence de presse je rappelle
que vous êtes ancien ambassadeur à
spécialiste de la rue cink ont fait